zuerst einmal das grundgesetz ist einer
der größten erfolge der deutschen
geschichte
wir feiern heuer sein 70 jähriges
bestehen das ist länger als jede
deutsche verfassung nimmt man einmal das
lange sicht des heiligen römischen
reiches deutscher nation aus der
deutsche bund des wiener kongress
erzielt 51 jahre von norddeutschen bund
bis zum ende des kaiserreiches dauert es
ebenfalls 51 jahre die die bismarker
reichsverfassung gilt und der weimarer
verfassung waren nur 13 jahre dauern
schätzt er ein verbrecherischer klinsi
zur makulatur machte allerdings meine
damen und herren ist dauer noch kein
wert an sich
das grundgesetz hat in diesen 70 jahren
auf den freiheitlichen und
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten start der
deutschen geschichte gestaltet und
bewahrt wenn manche historiker meinen
man könne aus der geschichte nichts
lernen dann beweist das grundgesetz das
gegenteil die verfassungsväter haben aus
den fehlern der weimarer
reichsverfassung lehren gezogen die das
grundgesetz ist jetzt so erfolgreich
gemacht haben
also könnte man meinen alles ist gut der
eine ganz ähnliche formulierung brachte
könige brinkhaus doch dem ist nicht so
verfassungen sind erst einmal buch
starken auch da haben sie völlig recht
kundige bringt er aus sie müssen gelebt
werden und von der gesellschaft die sie
verfassen immer aufs neue verteidigt
werden
und da meine damen und herren sieht es
weniger überzeugend aus ja natürlich
gibt es verfassungsfeinde links wie
rechts und auch im islamischen bereich
aber die sind leicht zu erkennen und zu
stellen
die wirkliche gefahr geht von denen aus
die das gleichgewicht zwischen freiheit
und gleichheit immer von neuem zu lasten
der freiheit verschieben wollen
sie geht von denjenigen aus die ihre
politischen ziele in die verfassung
hineininterpretieren um den politischen
diskurs zu verengen und so beschützt vom
grundgesetz vorteile im meinungskampf
zurück und freiheit kommt auf leisen
sohlen titelte die letzte welt am
sonntag und beschrieb die gefahren jener
politischen korrektheit die heute
unbequeme professoren trifft und morgen
soziale netzwerke in seiner berühmten
rede zum 8 mai 1945 sagte richard von
weizsäcker ich zitiere mit genehmigung
des präsidenten
wenn wir uns der verfolgung des freien
geistes während der diktatur besinnen
werden wir die freiheit jedes gedankens
und jeder kritik schützen so sehr sie
sich auch gegen uns selbst richten mag
meine damen haben
das grundgesetz ist ein rahmen in dem
vieles möglich ist
auch kevin kinos enteignungs fantasien
oder eine demokratische
identitätspolitik wie wir sie vertreten
das grundgesetz ist auch ein schutz für
minderheiten und minder meinungen gegen
die überwältigung fantasien
demokratischer mehrheiten
und weil wir das wissen als minderheit
schützen wir das grundgesetz was john
stuart mill und alexis de tocqueville im
neunzehnten jahrhundert als gefahren für
die freiheit ausgemacht haben haben die
verfassungsgebers des grundgesetzes
beherzigt und nach bestem wissen und
gewissen gebannt es ist an uns und da
stimme ich wieder mit den kollegen
brinkhaus überall dieses freiheitliche
regelwerk immer von neuem mit leben zu
erfüllen eine neue oder gar bessere
verfassung werden wir nicht bekommen so
wenig übrigens kollege bat wie eine neue
oder gar besser von national sich
bedanken